ringraziamo sì effettivamente le
maestranze bisogna dare atto che è vero
che io faccio il 99 per cento
insomma delle cose però anche quello un
per cento bisogna riconoscerlo come con
i musicisti sono molto felice devo dire
la verità
questa è una prima contaminazione
positiva che finalmente ho avuto
l'archetto perché io per anni fa ormai
da anni spettacoli nei teatri ma mi
danno sempre il filo non ho capito
perché il microfono col filo invece
finalmente un archetto come tiziano
ferro posso anche fare contaminare la
mia arte cantautorale anche con dei
balletti potrei anche fare sono un uomo
vero osso duro
posso fare anche questo questa è la mia
federer e l'altro io avevo portato
proprio le diapositive vere cioè proprio
con il proiettore quello che è non credo
perché me l'hanno bocciata per cui io
adesso un lettore mio diciamo innovativo
riusciranno 2047 probabilmente questo
dispositivo che si può anche chiudere
come un vecchio start up che permette di
selezionare ecco questa è una prima
diapositiva che voi potete vedere
immagini perché siete dotati
incredibilmente di un sistema 3d
no anche tu che stai usando il
telefonino non ha senso è un sistema 3d
che gli permette di vedervi in tutta la
mia bellezza e di tutte le mie
dimensioni che alcuni casi sono anche
quattro bene la
mio intervento che ho preparato per mesi
e mesi in maniera accurata come classico
della mia natura dura meticolosa è
perché io lavoro in maniera mai ora
pensate che sta improvvisando ma non è
così
in realtà nasce da una come si può
vedere da questa diapositiva che mi
ritrae da bambino
sì quello a fianco e mio fratello e c'è
anche mamma diranno se la potete notare
e anche la nonna la nonna che abbiamo in
comune anche nonna con la barba si aveva
la barba alla tradizione di famiglia
bene da piccolo io avevo un problema
proposito di contaminazioni e di virus
mi ammalavo sempre ho avuto tutte le
malattie possibili solo avuto avuto la
quarta la quinta la sesta malattia la
scarlattina che voi avrete letto forse
in piccole donne io l'ho avuta ho avuto
gli orecchioni due volte che quando è
successo la seconda volta mamma non ci
poteva credere ed è andata anche dal
medico preoccupata e il medico si ci
hanno avuto per la seconda volta ma io
li ho imparato che una contaminazione
poteva essere positiva perché in effetti
con la malattia tutto cambiava a casa
finalmente ero qualcuno ma quando quando
tu ti ammali da piccolo da che perché
voglio dire non era l'infanzia di adesso
dove i bambini sono costantemente
programmati per fare qualche cosa a noi
ci lasciavano sostanzialmente nel nulla
non esiste ri quando ce li ho passato
l'infanzia così in un paese piccolo si
chiamava di oggi in questo paese noi
giravamo liberamente fra le montagne
uscivamo il pomeriggio più ci cacciarono
fuori di casa meglio vera è la malattia
ti rendeva una persona speciale a tutti
poter guardare la televisione
una spremuta d'arancia tuo padre veniva
anche tuo padre a darti delle carezze
guarda che
era una cosa che io non so se è una cosa
che mi preoccupa di questo spiccio e che
è rimasto fermo a 10 minuti e non si
muove perché posso andare avanti
liberamente ma sto parlando con nessuno
e un po come avete positiva
ecco qui una seconda diapositiva che vi
fa vedere il mio padre mentre mi
accarezza visibile in effetti va
poverino devo dire che in effetti la
contaminazione per quanto mi riguarda
nasce proprio da mio padre e da mia
madre perché dovete sapere che io come
tiziano che avremo citato è l'anagramma
di notizia dario brunori non ci
crederete ma è l'anagramma di un raro
ibrido l'ho scoperto in quarta liceo
quando visto che fai tutti i giochi di
parole sperando noe calembour un raro
hibito perché dovete sapere che mio
padre che fa bruno ordinari non è un
cognome calabrese non s'è vista accorti
del mio sono calabrese nonostante la mia
dizione perfetta è mio padre era
romagnolo mia madre cosentina quindi
potete immaginare già quando loro due si
siano come contaminati vicendevolmente e
come noi che siamo stati frutto di una
contaminazione una contaminazione per
certi versi meravigliosa perché per
esempio il ragù di mamma è un ragù che
tiene insieme due tradizioni
meravigliose sulla carne in alcuni casi
questa contaminazione si è tradotta in
una sorta di frutto strano in cui noi
per esempio a casa non potevamo parlare
dialetto no
parlavamo l'italiano questo in un paese
come oggi un paese ridente della
calabria alla sua apertura
con la sua voglia anche no di provare
nuove esperienze di capire di
comprendere un bambino che invece dire
papà diceva babbo è che quando doveva
insultare un altro bambino diceva
sciocco di un gioiellino stracciato in
calabria
ora capite perché poi una 40 anni scrive
canzoni tristi no c'è una motivazione
per cui uno cresce in un certo modo
[Applauso]
ora questa strana combinazione di
fattori non legati a mio padre e mia
madre ci sono poi tradotti in una mia
attitudine che sempre in bilico
io mi sento sempre in bilico anche nel
mio rapporto con la modernità ora vi
faccio vedere questa diapositiva qui
ecco come potete vedere io sto decidendo
se lavorare su pc o su mac
perché la diatriba è sempre in a e c è
anche un pubblico meraviglioso se ride
the queste battute parentesi cosa veste
ed essere stata proprio mamma mi va bene
voglio dire se uno ride paratia triba pc
mac dicevo sono sempre in bilico anche
in questo mio rapporto con la modernità
mi sono sempre trovato in bilico fra la
parte di me che contiene appunto mio
nonno è quella parte invece che va verso
mio nipote
lo dico anche spesso nelle mie canzoni
c'è una canzone fa ma un capolavoro come
tutti i miei è inutile andare a dire le
cose scontate e banali ecco in ogni mio
pezzo
c'è questo attrito ed è per questo che
io ho sempre visto la contaminazione
comunque un aspetto positivo perché è
proprio fra nell'unione non è l'attrito
fra queste parti di me che nasce la
scintilla vitale
però io tendenzialmente sono contro la
contaminazione
cioè io nella mia testa un modello
perfetto io sono un procrastinato re
feriale cioè rimanderei costantemente il
momento in cui mi espongo il momento in
cui faccio un disco nel momento in cui
scrivo una cosa perché non mi sento mai
pronto è perché non mi sento mai pronto
perché ha un ideale di perfezione e mi
spaventa l'idea
di fare di qualcosa di imperfetto di far
sì che qualcosa possa contaminarmi e
possa contaminare l'idea che io ho di me
e invece nella vita ho imparato sin
dalle malattie che la contaminazione è
fondamentale che contaminarsi e proprio
l'essenza stessa della vita perché se ci
pensate io prima dicevo sono un virus il
virus che cos'è non si può definire come
un organismo vitale però è in effetti
una forma di vita che si lega ad
un'altra vita e in qualche modo quando
non è distruttiva stimola la vita stessa
la fa diventare più forte ci crea gli
anticorpi ci fa diventare qualcosa
d'altro e nella musica questa cosa
nola la viviamo in maniera diretta e a
volte anche inconsapevole perché io
molte delle cose che vivo male vivo col
pensiero né vivo in un altro piano che
su un altro piano che è quello
sentimentale prime musica succede una
cosa bellissima
succede per esempio negli strumenti ad
arco io lo dico sempre che è il momento
in cui l'archetto attrito con la corda
possono succedere tante cose
può succedere che da quella attrito
scaturisca un suono stridulo e terribile
quindi i due elementi entrano in
contrasto non producono una melodia
oppure se uno studia e si prepara e
gestisce quella attrito quella attrito
potrà fuori una melodia straordinaria
una meraviglia meravigliosa
ecco quando io penso alla contaminazione
non penso che debba essere positiva
tukur penso che farò una contaminazione
sia proprio come l'archetto con la corda
bisogna solo che impariamo un po a
gestirla
[Applauso]
a proprio archetto me lo tolgo non so
cosa ho detto ma l'ho detto molto bene
considerando che non avevo preparato
nulla
come si vede da questa diapositiva
scusate stavo bene eccola in cui si vede
che sono qui stravaccato sul divano a
guardare serie televisive bene tra
l'altro fra le malattie che ho avuto
e questo mi piace molto ce n'era una
adesso anche un doppio microfono grazie
anche tra l'altro il gelato ma stasera
mi state proprio iniziando il gelato è
un'altra cosa meravigliosa con cui puoi
fare quella cosa così ora voi non lo
sapete che lo magari vede i talent ma
perché il cantante fa così perché
purtroppo c'è una qui c'è un
condensatore che si riscalda e quindi il
cantante non riesce proprio a tenere le
dita e si scotta
per questo spesso io preferisco la st io
da sempre ho detto a sta sempre bene con
questa direi che stacco tutto con che
avete una pazienza va via
devo dire incredibile ma come mi lascia
un attimo contaminare devo dire che in
effetti come si può vedere da questa
diapositiva sto facendo trekking che una
volta era una camminata è un po come
spiccio no ecco le contaminazioni sono
quest'anno speech m'ha chiamato l'altra
volta il mio manager mi ha detto dario
dobbiamo fare una call per un
brainstorming cui parliamo di un panel
in cui dovrei fare uno speech e io l'ho
fatto come si può vedere dall'ultima
diapositiva con cui vi saluto
lasciate di contaminare soprattutto dai
punti di vista altrui
secondo me c'è la ragione anche vega
ci incazziamo per i cani abbandonati poi
ci passiamo di insaccati fondo dare
parliamo sempre di salvini di immigrati
clandestini ma non campo rifugiati non
c'hanno questo mano
secondo me non è che devi esagera
ora lotta al capitale ogni tanto ci
vuole andare
furlan centro commerciale e lo so che o
disgusto disonesto e criminale ma
d'estate si sta
e poi sempre parcheggiare
secondo me secondo me
io vedo il mondo
secondo me
descrivo al molo sud
secondo me mi sono mai
invece
visto che
chissà dove
[Musica]
e stato
secondo me trattiamo però poi vederci
sono troppo l'auto
anche se solo un raffreddore
c'è una cosa
mi fa spavento
nel mondo cede alta e questo
l'imperativo
dove di muovere
ci siamo
di sporcarci
zarate
a tutto sarà anche o cantastorie ogni
volta e per un certo
se non c'è
un muratore
secondo me
si va dal mondo
le scrivo ma secondo me
[Musica]
questo dottore
chissà dove
disputate le
secondo me
dopo persona 18 e ci vogliamo bene
ma torniamo insieme ma che ci sarebbe un
prete un messo comunale
se c'è una cosa naturale e doversi dare
un bacio davanti a un pubblico ufficiale
[Musica]
secondo me
desiderano
su
non me
e stato
visto da te
chissà come
secondo
[Musica]
grazie
vivere come volare ci si può riuscire
soltanto poggia su cosa
[Musica]
d'altronde non si può ignorare
la voce che dice oltre alle stelle
c'è un posto migliore
[Musica]
buongiorno paolo ti viene la voglia di
andare
vedete di andare a scoprire sempre
[Musica]
non sia soltanto una scatola può all
ultima ruolo
murdoch grande
[Musica]
ma che a dirlo
a kurt cobain
come ci si senta star
sopra un piedistallo
[Musica]
che ha
quanto la balanza in gara e quando ci si
può
e non provare
[Musica]
provate a dirlo
beh
[Musica]
[Applauso]
da dire
[Musica]
vivere come nota
ci si può riuscire soltanto resta
sul tavolo
trona non si può tacere
la voce che dice
dominio
e proprio quel giorno
viera lavoro
di andare a vedere
sarà solo per essa
il senso profondo di tutto la cosa lo
puoi ritrovare soltanto guardando
trionfo
[Musica]
ma chiare
kurt cobain
ma ci si santa stare
sopra un bene st
[Musica]
marylin tanto l'apparenza inganna
e quando ci si può
[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
[Musica]
[Applauso]
viveur come sogna
ci si può riuscire
mi auguro luce
a dormire
[Musica]
grazie mille